jean marc bonjour les responsables
économiques ont très peur des nouvelles
mesures de confinement qui ruinerait
disent certains experts l'activité
quels sont les éléments qui permettent
de juger de ses conséquences
oui à tout et c'est assez compliqué à
définir mais nous sommes plongés c'est
vrai dans un débat qui est devenu un peu
hystérique et même insupportable et
responsables politiques
les médecins à beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprises sont dans l'incertitude la
plus totale
d'où ce sentiment finalement de
cafouillage d'incohérences qui n'est pas
d'un sentiment d'ailleurs c'est pas un
réalité qu il va falloir assumer le fait
que les mesures de confinement pourrait
ruiner l'économie pour sauver des vies
humaines
il faudrait accepter d'arrêter les
systèmes de production prendre le risque
de créer de la misère qui serait
peut-être pire d'ailleurs que le coït 19
ans bref on nous dit et bien si vous
voulez garder votre job
eh bien il va falloir accepter de perdre
des vies et notamment des vies de
seniors ou de gens qui sont à risque qui
sont qui sont plutôt aux malades en
fragilité personne ne peut accepter un
tel chantage de personnes c'est un choix
impossible pour le chef d'entreprise
impossible pour l'homme politique
insoutenable c'est horrible alors oui on
va si on arrête l'économie si on freine
économie on va ralentir la production de
richesses bien sûr cette année on va
perdre 11 12 ou 13% de pim c'est-à-dire
de production industrielle brute la
richesse que l'on crève va diminuer le
premier confinement a déjà coûté 450
milliards d'euros si l'on confine à
nouveau là en décembre on peut voir dans
quatre semaines et bien on va encore
perdre
selon bercy entre 15 et 20 milliards
parce que on va falloir payer du chômage
partiel
il va falloir supporter obligé de fermer
disparaître notamment les plus faibles
les commerces vont encore souffrir les
bars les restaurants les théâtres oui
les fêtes de noël derrière tout ça pour
être chamboulé tout cela est vrai c'est
vrai
méchaal est ni la guerre ni la fin du
monde l'ordi la guerre dès la fin du
monde est pour beaucoup c'est leur vie
qui va être chamboulé le nombre de
pauvres sans emploi et sans abri va
s'accroître
c'est vrai c'est vrai et alors que la
pandémie touche tous les pays de la même
façon actuellement en europe
vous en avez qui s'en sortent quand même
un peu mieux que d'autres
au niveau économique l'allemagne par
exemple la suisse la norvège mais les
systèmes économiques étaient mieux
organisés les allemands avaient un
système économique avec des réserves il
n'était pas endetté nous sommes endettés
à plus de 100%
nous n'avons pas de marge pour supporter
tout ça la france qui va sans doute
souffrir est aussi celle qui va dépenser
le plus d'argent pour éviter les
douleurs on a mis des perfusions sociale
partout ce qui n'est quand même pas le
cas en grande-bretagne ce qui n'est pas
le cas aux états unis où la misère
progresse à la vitesse grand v
supérieure à celle du virus cette crise
voyez vous l a entretenu une sorte de
panique alors qu'elle n'a rien détruit
on n'en parle pas hormis bien sûr hormis
des vies humaines mais les usines sont
en état les moyens de production n'ont
pas été détruits les voies de chemin de
fer les équipements les routes les
autoroutes les camions pourraient rouler
les avions pourrait voler les aéroports
sont encore ouverts donc ça peut
fonctionner il ne manque qu'une chose la
confiance le coc vie d'un terrible il
appliquer la clé du moteur il fait peur
à tout le monde et il totalise tout le
monde mais dès qu'on aurait retrouvé si
on avait retrouvé la confiance et bien
ça pourrait repartir très vite puisque
rien n'a été abîmé le restaurateur
pourrait retrouver ses cuisines le bar
pourrait rouvrir il a rien à réparer il
revêt ses stocks
la majorité des contrats de travail a
même été sauvé par le chômage partiel
dont l'économie non elle n'est pas
ruiner les chefs d'entreprise le savent
le président du medef l'a d'ailleurs dit
hier soir pas question de se mettre en
travers des mesures de confinement pour
sauver un bilan il a fait le choix
courageux d'essayer de sauver le maximum
de vies humaines
oui mais de tout cela va représenter des
sommes colossales qu'il faudra bien
payer
jean-marc oui alors c'est évidemment le
grand stress auquel tout le monde pense
qu'il s'ajoute au stress du coc vite ça
vient du fait qu'on ne sait pas d'où
vient cet argent les 450 milliards dont
je vous parlais il ya un sport pour le
premier confirmant les gaz 20 milliards
qu'il faudra donner les 100 milliards
qu'il faudra pour le plan de relance
l'année prochaine alors cet argent c'est
de l'argent qu'on emprunte ont
l'empreinte on permet de lier aux chefs
d'entreprise dans l'empreinte et les
fameux pge les plans garanties par
l'état
et puis je vais vous dire qu'on a
actuellement aucun mal à emprunter de
l'argent à un taux très bas donc ça
c'est très facile c'est une facilité
heureusement que nous avons peut-être
facilité ce qui pourrait nous font
confiance
il pense donc qu'on va s'en sortir le
premier marqueur de crise grave
c'est en général c'est la bourse ce sont
les marchés financiers quand ça va mal
la bourse crac et bien depuis le début
de la crise les bourses du monde entier
n'ont pas craqué elles n'ont pas craqué
l on bougeait bien mais elles sont à l'
équilibre les boursiers les
investisseurs savent pour l'instant que
les appareils de production ne sont pas
détruits ils peuvent repartir
donc pour répondre à ma question comment
on va payer ses dettes
pour l'instant dans l'immédiat par les
pannes des français elle est colossal on
enfourne possum pas donc on bourre les
condés parle j'en ai par des pagnes
concourir à part les bagnes étrangères
aussi y compris et ça c'est un paradoxe
les parcs chinoises parlent que les
chinois ont des normes qui excédent et
le jour où on aura vraiment besoin
croyez moi ils arriveront et puis plus
tard l'année prochaine par des revenus
de la croissance mais la croissance elle
ne reviendra que le jour où le virus
aura fait qui va me jean-marc sylvestre
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions